a little better reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey we are going to
watch the series finale episode of Game
of Thrones oh my gosh we've come a long
way let's have fun and enjoy this before
we go into that a couple of things
because this is the final episode we are
going to have a two-parter for this of
reaction highlights the YouTube videos
we can only show about 10 minutes worth
of footage per video so there's only
gonna be a part 1 and part 2 there will
be a full length reaction stream along
and usually even these reaction highs
there's plenty of stuff cut out but
there will be a full reaction stream
along over our patreon page over there
we do reactions to several shows that
are streaming along as those are attack
on Titan my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood one punch man
Cobra Kai season 2 Jon did all of
haunting of Hill House supernatural and
of course Game of Thrones
several of the shows do have reaction
how that's included as well those are
attack on Titan one punch man Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood and supernatural
we also do weekly Q&A and much further
stuff lastly Erik my man at nerd chronic
thank you so much for all the editing
you've done for us on these videos we
grace him with this lovely task of happy
to to these reaction highlights for the
show he's worked with people like Eamon
snow aqus on a lot of work over at the
Schmo down he has his own podcasts on
YouTube whoever podcaster found please
follow him at the nura chronic this guy
is a very very very very awesome awesome
dude love chatting with him I text him
often these days so yeah let's get into
this
we've all come a long way we've all been
very divisive about this season
we've all had a lot of fun and that's
what's important let's they have worked
their asses off they have
at ten million dollars in episode so 1
million of that apparently goes to
Cersei let's just let's just try our
best to appreciate everything that are
going for it or wrap this epic series up
Oh God grey worm I hope this is the
series from now Terry and just walking
around very slowly good we spent 10
minutes to his hair that's poetic
[Music]
they don't look that bad from doing
crusty and they're totally shot that was
a beautiful shot
[Music]
all right
[Music]
that's world world-dominating evil now
okay we've come this far
[Music]
oh just gonna go to the crowd and go all
the rightful heir guys don't worry it's
over now my brother of you is gonna tell
you the whole story doesn't talk very
loud though unless you control it dragon
at this point not drone I'm missile left
well are you got there fast
[Music]
the wars did you not just listen to what
she said was it cuz he doesn't speak oh
it doesn't understand what she's saying
okay yeah we could read subtitles this
is the most insane she's [ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
somebody knows this show oh yeah
[Music]
Tyrian kabisa
why do you think something told me the
truth about you and you have to choose
now you should put on an act at least
right now in front of that guard I know
at least this way it won't be hard to
adjust to it outside up dinner do not
see edge right
[Music]
I'm just letting you know I was you want
that's just the right house scam to get
the building survived it's the iron
all this music is great though this
whole light
Wow
all she really wanted that
whoo you better sit on that thing quick
don't worry guys John's gonna go sit on
her lap yeah that's how they don't get
to choose
[Music]
a stabber No
[Music]
she didn't even get to sit on my door
hisses sir
Danny deserve better run the [ __ ] out of
that City job yes drogon [ __ ] him up man
[Music]
[Music]
this show better not back home that show
that dragon better Gilliam is better by
descent or something
[Music]
Oh
the most emotion I've seen
Oh
and you'd always sit on the Iron Throne
called it
[Music]
I can't wait for Gurgaon 20 men
[Music]
except for the show that even premiere
it was like no laughter
[Music]
why didn't he kill John why didn't he
kill John my guy's jaundice
[Music]
the true love story she's going off with
her just good take this ago thanks for
watching part one guys make sure to hop
on over to part two